well I'm very sorry for the disruption
today it's been a difficult day and I am
sorry that audiences have been affected
and they haven't got the programming as
a keen sports fan I know uh like
everyone that to miss programming is a
real blow and I am sorry about that we
are working very hard
um to resolve the situation and make
sure that we get output back on air
how are you working to resolve the
situation then well I don't want to go
into too much detail about exact
discussion I think I think everyone
wants to calmly resolve the situation I
mean I would say Gary lineker is a
superb broadcaster he's the best in the
business that's not for debate he's he's
well I think we've I won't go through
all the history but we are where we are
and I think that he is an outstanding
broadcaster he's brilliant broadcaster
and to be clear success for me is Gary
gets back on air and together we are
giving to the audiences that world-class
Sports coverage which as I say I'm sorry
we haven't been able to deliver today so
you're sorry about that are you sorry
about the way you've handled it are you
sorry about the fact that you've taken
him off there well I think we we've made
decisions and I've made decisions
based on a real passion about what the
BBC is and it's difficult it's this
balance between free speech and
impartiality and I honestly do not
believe despite a lot of the commentary
that this is about left or right
it's about our ability we're Fierce
champions of democratic debate Free
Speech but with that comes the need to
create an impartial organization has
made lots of comments before you allowed
him to criticize the Qatari government
on the BBC why was this different is it
because he attacked the UK government no
absolutely not this is nothing to do
with anything to do with the specifics
of the wearer Tweet is sent and I'll
talk in general terms but it's about
party getting involved in partly
political matters now what I would say
is I'm listening hard this has been a
tough time for the BBC and we care about
our audiences we want to get the right
outcome for this we're working very hard
to get that done
and I would like to see Gary lineker
return on air on the BBC
now with that we have to listen I think
we think we have to do a bit of thinking
about the balance between you know how
you are delivering impartiality
and also the ability for people to
particularly Freelancers to say things
online and we're in a new age that
requires guidelines it says the risk is
lower when an individual is expressing
views publicly on unrelated area for
example a sports presenter how is it
that for someone who has made
impartiality it's big things three and a
half years it's right two and a half
years that you've been dealing yeah but
during that period you've not even
agreed what impartiality is with your
most high profile and highest paid
presenter isn't that a catastrophic
mistake no I think we are in an evolving
situation where there's always some
judgment and what I want to do is listen
find a balanced reasonable solution
where we've said people want to be able
to express opinions I understand that I
have only one objective which is to make
sure the BBC is truly impartial that
we're doing that in a balanced way and I
think we need to listen and reflect on
the guidelines and your points are valid
which is are we are we clear across the
board why this time it's different
with Gary lineker you know you're
questioning his impartiality but there
are lots of people who are questioning
yours
they are saying that you buckled
under under pressure from the UK
government the conservative party of
which you were once a member an official
and the right-wing press to take action
against Gary act to take action against
Gary lineker is that true is it the UK
government the right-wing press all of
that that made it different for you this
time this absolutely not anyone who
knows me by the way knows that we are in
the BBC and myself are absolutely driven
by a passion for impartiality not left
right or pandering to a particular party
to say I support your migrant policy I
back it it's brilliant he would be
taking an opinion would you have removed
him from that from there
I'm not going to go through I'm not
going to go through all the
hypotheticals of the past well I'm going
to say what I would say very clearly
is we we deal with these things on an
ongoing basis I think there are some
questions coming from this period which
has been difficult there are some
questions about making sure and it's a
fair it's a fair challenge are we
totally clear on those guidelines for
Freelancers we're going to remove well
are you going to remove sir Lord
Karen Brady Chris Packham presenters who
also give their opinions why aren't they
okay well the current guidelines
um as they exist today and I I do want
to reflect on those guidelines do draw
Extinction between those people who are
seen as pan BBC figures who work on big
BBC events who for that just that are
different to those that are appearing on
progress we can debate that I'm in
listening mode I want to make sure that
going forward we have a workable
solution let's be clear we've got the
best sports broadcaster in the world we
want to make sure
that he can come back on air we work
together to make that happen and
everyone wants to see a reasonable
solution to this and that's where I am I
am really focused on getting to a
solution working quickly together to
make it happen I'm going to wrap up
shortly but you've suspended Gary
lineker for an anti-government tweet and
of course there are questions being
asked about Richard Sharp the chairman
of the BBC who is being investigated
facilitating a loan for the former prime
minister Boris Johnson why is he still
in a job to be very clear we asked Gary
to step back in terms of the chairman I
have a lot of responsibilities in this
job for thousands of people one thing I
don't do is the appointment of the chair
and it's a different process you know
the the you know the the the the the way
in which the board is hired and that
role is a different thing to editorally
me running the BBC making those
decisions trying to be fair and getting
a BBC that is truly impartial and boy we
should be fighting for this in this
world calmly rationally fighting for a
BBC that really actually Champions free
speech and my last question to you
impartiality is a big value for the BBC
but so is trust right now there are many
people in the UK that simply do not
trust you
do you think you should resign
absolutely not I think my job is to
serve license fee players and deliver a
BBC those really focused on world-class
impartial Landmark output and I look
forward to us resolving this situation
and looking forward to delivering that